[Applause]
[Music]
i think there is no doubt
switzerland is one of the most
exceptional dazzling and amazing
countries in the world
despite being nestled between mountains
and not having any remarkable natural
resources it has become one of the
richest states on the planet it is also
a country full of curiosities for
example it is the place where milk
chocolate was invented for some
a delicacy and for others a sacrilege it
is also here where the best watches in
the world
are made with apologies to the apple
watch and it even has four official
languages despite having fewer
than nine million inhabitants and that's
not all we are talking about a country
so peculiar that it doesn't even have a
capital and no
if right now you're already pulling your
hair out and shouting at the screen
burn burn hold your horses because the
truth is that this city is only the
designated seat of the federal council
that is the home of the swiss government
which yes in practice is
like being the capital but without
anything official that recognizes it as
such
however for this kind of alpine paradise
with a more than enviable natural
environment to also be one of the freest
and most democratic countries
as well as one of the least corrupt in
the world there must be something else
on that list of curiosities
after all good chocolate can work
miracles but not that many well the
truth is that there is something else
this is where the swiss political system
comes in
[Music]
which has been labelled by many analysts
of modern politics as
little short of a utopia a thing so rare
today that it well deserves a full
visual politic video to explain it
you see switzerland's political system
is based on three fundamental principles
decentralization federalism and direct
democracy we are talking about a country
in which citizens have been directly
deciding on the most important issues of
state policy
for more than a century in fact in
switzerland we can even find what are
known as communes their unusual
municipalities where the villagers meet
periodically to decide things and vote
by a show of hands
this is called landscaminder
of course getting such a model to work
so well has not been a matter of just a
few years
switzerland as we know it today began to
take shape in 1848 when it evolved from
a simple confederation of independent
cantons
into a modern state with a central
government although with highly
decentralized power you could say that
the cantons are something like the
states in the united states the
autonomous communities in spain
or the lenders in germany but with a
much greater political
financial and managerial autonomy in
total there are 26 cantons and more than
2 000 communes the equivalent of
municipalities
[Music]
therefore the swiss cantons are in
charge of managing secondary education
health
culture cantonal infrastructure and
security at the police level and yes
for this they can decide independently
how much to charge and how to collect
and manage their own taxes
then below the cantons are the communes
which manage primary education and more
local services such as street cleaning
or village security
as a result the central state is
responsible only for functions that
concern the country as a whole
such as foreign policy the armed forces
or the high-capacity infrastructure that
supports the entire state
everything else is the responsibility of
the territorial bodies cantons
and communes but at this point i'm sure
you're eager to know more about this
unusual political system
so do you want to know more about a
country where presidents are only in
power
for one year and the ministers are from
different political parties well let's
take a look at it and what better way to
start
than taking a look at its famous system
of direct democracy
[Music]
direct democracy utopia realized
here's a question if i ask you to think
of a perfect democracy your ideal
democracy what would it be what would it
look like i'm sure that for many of you
the answer lies in a model in which
citizens do not simply vote every four
years
and then let their representatives do an
undo as they please
well switzerland is often referred to as
the country of the eternal election
campaign it's quite likely that if you
ever get the opportunity to travel there
you will see electoral posters asking
for a vote in favor or against one issue
or another the swiss vote
three to four times a year on specific
national policy issues
then there are parliamentary elections
every four years the cantonal elections
and the communal elections
which in some places are even more
popular than those at a higher level
which is an anomaly compared to the rest
of the world
[Music]
the swiss can also launch popular
initiatives and referendums for example
popular initiatives are an instrument by
which a citizen can propose a bill that
must be voted on in parliament if it
gathers more than 100 000 signatures of
support
and although this initiative exists in
many other democracies the truth is that
in most countries the rigidity of the
requirements the overlapping with other
regulations
and the lack of habit and political
culture mean that they're rarely
processed
then there are also referendums which in
switzerland unlike in other countries
may be proposed not only by the
government but can also be proposed by
the citizens themselves
yes yes that's exactly what i said
referendums are votes organized with the
aim of approving a regulation of
considerable social importance or
overturning one already approved by
parliament to carry them forward
50 000 signatures are required half as
many as in the case of popular
initiatives
this is where political culture and the
mobilization of civil society come into
play in switzerland there are pressure
groups with different agendas that can
collect this number of signatures in a
relatively short period of time
something that would obviously be very
complicated for an individual citizen in
addition the constitution cannot undergo
any change without a vote by the
citizens themselves
any modification whatever the section
must be endorsed by a vote as well as
any proposal for the country's joining
of certain international agreements
these are the so-called mandatory
referendums
to give you an idea of what all this
means in an ordinary year like
2021 four popular consultations will be
held one on march seven
one on june 13th another on september
26th and the last one
on november 28th it should be noted
however that for a popular initiative or
a mandatory referendum to be approved
or rejected it is not only necessary for
the swiss citizens to vote
for or against it the cantons also vote
as if they were entities in themselves
in a kind of binding over election and
to make it even more complicated not all
26 cantons have the same weight when it
comes to voting
among the 26 cantons there are 20 full
cantons and 6.
let's call them half cantons in the
sense that their vote is worth half
this means that in practice a referendum
could be rejected with the opposition of
only 12 cantons and since cantonal votes
do not take population into accounts it
could be the case that a group of
sparsely populated cantons could
overturn an initiative even if a
minority of voters reside there now
how is the vote of the different cantons
determined for this the result of the
consultation at the canton level
is taken into account if the majority of
citizens of the canton vote in favour in
the cantona vote will be in favor
they are basically additional
counterweights created with the
intention of reinforcing stability and
preventing more densely populated areas
from having
all the decision-making power now don't
tell me it's not a surprising
and impressive system but as you can see
the direct democracy model is somewhat
more complex
than just arriving and voting on one
initiative or another to achieve success
in one of these votes
civil society organizations are needed
as well as the means to overcome the
existing counterweights but
wait a minute what about the
representatives how do they legislate in
switzerland
what is their legislative power like how
does it work exactly
is it as unusual as what we've seen so
far well let's take a look
[Music]
the most surprising legislative power
the first thing to note is that the
swiss legislative system is bicameral
that is there are two chambers of
representation when proposing and
passing laws
in switzerland's case there is a chamber
that represents the citizens the
national council this is the lower
chamber and is composed of 200
representatives who are elected
by cantonal constituencies meaning that
the cantons with the largest populations
have more seats and then there is a
second chamber which is the council of
states which represents the cantons and
would be something roughly equivalent to
the senate
the council of states has 46
representatives two for each of the 20
full cantons and one for each of the six
half-cantons in other words
in this upper chamber the population of
each canton is irrelevant in the
distribution of seats this is done in
order to reinforce the search for a
broad consensus covering the largest
number of territories and thus
prevent the most populous cantons from
determining all decisions the fact is
that between the two between both
chambers they form the so-called federal
assembly and sometimes for very specific
matters both chambers meet jointly
resulting in the united federal assembly
but wait a minute because the
curiosities do not end there
the fact is that switzerland has one of
the most fragmented political systems in
the world
for example take a look at the
composition of the national council
because this is
in fact key to everything that we're
going to tell you as you can see the
swiss parliament is characterized by
being very fragmented or depending on
how you look at it by having a lot of
political
plurality there are between three and
four major parties with a very similar
presence and about seven others with
parliamentary representation at first
glance this political scenario would
surely indicate a situation of
ungovernability to get so many different
parties to agree what a nightmare right
but no
this is not the case in switzerland
[Music]
swiss politics is one of consensus
multi-partyism and co-participation in
fact to give you an idea the president
of the national council is allowed to
serve for only one year then
every year another person is elected
president of the parliament and yes
that person is usually from a different
party than the previous president you
could say that in switzerland there is
an
idea that the concentration of power in
just a few hands must be avoided at all
costs and one of the formulas they found
was the annual limitation of mandates
and a system that forces agreements
between the different parties now does
that sound strange to you well you'll
see when we tell you how the federal
government works but before we get to
that let me tell you one last thing
about the legislative branch its
functions
[Music]
obviously in a country as decentralized
as switzerland the national parliament
also has limited functions
for example it is mainly involved in
approving laws and regulations of the
state as long as these do not encroach
on the numerous competencies of the
cantons it is also responsible for the
amendments to the constitution and the
approval of international treaties which
then as we have mentioned have to be
submitted to mandatory referendums
but perhaps the two most important
functions it has are on the one hand the
appointment of the attorney general who
unlike in most countries
is not appointed by the government but
voted by all parties and then the most
important of all is the election of the
members of the federal council
and its presidents the federal council
being the name given in switzerland to
the central government because yes the
swiss system is also a parliamentary
system so that the president of the
federal council is not elected directly
by the people but by the representatives
but hold on a moment because there is
much much more to be said
about the federal council which is
basically the swiss government it is
possible that we are looking at the
strangest government in the world
and at the same time one of the best
performing a system of government that
would surely fail in almost any other
country but which
nevertheless in switzerland has brought
stability unity and cultural diversity
and yes
also progress wealth and freedom would
you like to know what this extraordinary
system of government looks like well
let's take a look
[Music]
the world's artist government
i'm going to tell you something that may
seem strange to many of you during the
year of 2019 the president of the swiss
confederation was alimora in 2020 it was
simonetta somaruga and as of today in
2021 it is guy parmelon yes that's right
and no don't panic we're not talking
about an epic political crisis
swiss federal presidents are only in
power for one year from january the 1st
to december 31st during what is called
the presidential year so at the
beginning of december each year the
united federal assembly meets to elect
the president for the new presidential
year who will almost
certainly be from a different political
party than the previous year what's more
the same person cannot be re-elected for
the following year it has to be a
different one however the person chosen
must be one of the seven members of the
federal council who can be re-elected
every four years without any problem
okay so has your head exploded already
well bear with me because there's more
the swiss federal government is governed
by the so-called directorial system this
means that all seven members of the
government have exactly the same status
in terms of decision-making power and
rights within the government no one is
higher on the ladder than anyone else
yes that's right switzerland is
currently the only country in the world
with a government that is basically a
collegial body the president
simply presides over meetings and
represents the government in its foreign
relations but that's it
nothing more
[Music]
in addition the government has for many
years been formed by four political
parties and the two plus two plus two
plus one formula is usually followed to
distribute
the seats among the four most voted
parties do you remember what we were
telling you before about parliamentary
fragmentation well here it is
[Music]
and to make things even more complicated
when it comes to forming the federal
council that is the government
not only are the political parties taken
into account but also cultural diversity
for this reason
of these seven council members four come
from the german speaking part
two from the french speaking part and
one from the italian speaking part
this way the composition of the
government is similar to the cultural
distribution of the swiss population so
that no one complains
the fact is that in the end everything
that we're telling you about the federal
government has a practical effect
consensus let's say that you're not
going to see a member of the swiss
government throughout a decision taken
by the majority of the government as
happens in many countries such as italy
or spain for example the idea is that
all seven members have to argue all
decisions as their own
even if they don't like them
individually you know sometimes i give
in sometimes you give in and that's how
the swiss government works doesn't it
seem like it's from another planet the
truth is my friends is that the swiss
political system is perhaps
one of the best for many reasons it
combines direct democracy with
decentralization which is embodied in
federalism and it also guarantees
cohesion in a very culturally diverse
society and all this while promoting
multi-partyism and consensus politics
piece of cake
however hold on a moment because like
everything in life there are some
challenges that this system is going to
have to face
especially in the future challenges that
include many that are very recent and of
course did not exist when this system
was first designed and implemented do
you want to know exactly what we're
talking about well listen up
[Music]
nothing is quite perfect
the swiss political system is very old
and it still works very well but when it
was created the society and the country
were not exactly as they are today one
of the problems
so to speak is that ultimately
switzerland basically has a kind of
federalist veto for example a law passed
by the national council can be rejected
by the council of states which
represents the cantons regardless of
demographic distribution and this can
also happen in popular votes as we told
you before a reform of the constitution
for example can be voted in
favor by the citizen vote and overturned
by the cantonal vote
and don't think this is too complicated
the 13 small accountants which account
for only 11
of the voters have blocking power so
even if the other 89
of voters were to vote unanimously in
favor the small ones could overturn the
decision and vice versa we are talking
about an imbalance that has been growing
over time and that currently seems very
pronounced but in addition to the de
facto federalist veto there is another
problem that is also of great concern
[Music]
over the past 50 years switzerland has
welcomed a number of immigrants to the
extent that more than 20
of the resident population of
switzerland is now foreign there are
more than half a million people with a
foreign mother tongue and there are also
some 400 000 muslims now why is this
important well the challenge
or problem is that only swiss citizens
can participate in swiss federal
politics
and then only a minority of cantons and
communes allow foreign residents to vote
and of course getting citizenship is
also very complicated so let's say that
there is a growing percentage of the
population that is virtually excluded
from political life
at least when it comes to participating
anyway as you can see the swiss
political system is anything but
ordinary it is a combination of
curiosities peculiarities
and counterweights that undoubtedly make
it a unique system with many advantages
and yes also with some drawbacks and now
at this point the question i would like
to ask you is what do you think of the
swiss political system do you think that
in your country in your society it would
be possible to have such a system
as always leave your answers here below
in the comments and if you found this
video interesting don't forget to like
and subscribe to our channel best
regards
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there
you